revoyez tous bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ce matin sur
rtl france alors lors du premier tour
déjà c'est un chili très conservateur
qui s'est exprimée dans les urnes avec
l'arrivée en tête d'antonio cast est ce
que finalement le résultat que l'on a
aujourd'hui cette confrontation entre
deux candidats que tout oppose est la
conséquence directe de la révolte
populaire de 2019
oui en tout cas c'est un reflet
indirectes de cette grande explosion
sociale qui ailleurs en 2019 les les
attentes des chiliens et chiliennes sont
sont toujours là sont très très fortes
dans un modèle économique qui est
violent inégalitaire et donc finalement
ces élections polarisé entre la gauche
et l'extrême droite c'est aussi le
reflet d'une société qui a polarisé de
deux modèles qui vont être dessiné dans
cette dans ce deuxième tour des
élections c'est vraiment deux options
politiques assez proposée qui est que va
prendre le chili et qui va vraiment
influencer la possibilité ou pas d'en
finir avec l'héritage de la dictature
alors deux candidats aux visions
politiques
radicalement différente qu'elle ancrage
ont-ils dans la société chilienne et
surtout quels sont leurs projets pour le
père pourra le pays
alors la question des ancrages c'est
important puisqu'on a vu que presque 50
% de la population chilienne du corps
électoral ne va pas voter donc il ya une
grande partie des classes populaires
qu'il ne se sent pas représenté ni par
boric ni à la droite d'ailleurs donc là
il ya un défi très important pour ce
deuxième tour savoir comment on va
mobiliser ces secteurs-là autour d'un
des deux projets et d'autres pas la
question essentielle c'est pour boric
prétendre donc incarner
j'm'en la fin en partie en tout cas du
néolibéralisme les réformes sociales la
nouvelle constitution en cours de
rédaction et pour cast incarner le
retour alors
la vision très conservatrice anti
féministe anti migrants
revendiquant l'héritage de la dictature
donc deux projets bien distincts on al
impression qu également que le chili
suis un petit peu la tendance qui est
observé dans les autres pays d'amérique
latine
exactement on veut dire que cros et
antonio cas c'est une sorte de bol sauna
au chilien donc il ya une bonne
sonorisation au sens de vos leçons a
hole le président ben brésilien une
extrême droite latino-américaine qui
gagnent de l'espace qu'un peu partout et
au chili c'est le cas en s'appuyant ta
montre d'ailleurs sur les églises les
églises évangéliques les secteurs
catholiques conservateurs un homme sorte
de contrecoup face aux grandes
mobilisations 2019 donc contre l'option
féministe contre le droit à l'avortement
c'est une réaction face à toutes ces
évolutions sociales dans une société la
cité fiennes qui reste quand même
conservatrice est marqué par a parlé
thériault de l'héritage autoritaire de
pinocchio alors vous l'avez dit une
grande partie de la population à chillan
qui risque de ne pas participer à ces
élections elles ne se sont pas prêts
concernés ni par l'un ni par l'autre des
candidats
une situation assez difficile avec de
nombreux défis finalement qui attendent
le futur président s'il ya
de nombreux défis et effectivement dans
un contexte qui sera de toute manière
complexe puisqu'il ya aussi les
élections parlementaires et on voit que
aussi bien le sénat que le parlement
sont divisées quasiment en deux donc il
va falloir négocier pour le nouveau
président toutes les mesures un peu
phare du mandat à partir de mars
prochain et puis il faut rappeler qu'en
parallèle il ya une convention
constitutionnelle qui va déboucher sur
une nouvelle constitution il y aura un
référendum
durant l'été de l'année prochaine et
donc on va se retrouver dans un
climat politique assez incertain
nouvelle constitution
pouvoir parlementaire assez divisés et
des demandes sociales qui sont toujours
là et très certainement de grandes
mobilisations sociales à venir pour
l'année qui vient en résumé quel que
soit leur résultat finalement le chili
n'est pas sorti d'affaires
exactement on est dans un nouveau cycle
historique d'une certaine manière le
vieux monde est en train de mourir le
vieux monde de l'héritage autoritaire
mais avec de grandes incertitudes sur
verre ou va et le chili dans ce nouveau
cycle historique démocratisation ou
retour vers un héritage plus autoritaire
merci beaucoup en tout cas franck
gaudichaud d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
professeur en études latino-américaines
à milliards cité à toulouse jean jaurès